اشهر ثمانيه عجاف مرت على القوات الروسيه
في اوكرانيا خسائر فادحه في الارواح
والعتاد وغضب شعبي استدعت كلها ردا نادرا
من وزاره الدفاع
تلقاها اللواء 55 بالقرب من منطقه دونيتز
570 جنديا نال عليهم قصف كثيف نجا منهم
130 وبقيت شهاداتهم تعكس المعاناه
رايت رجالا يتمزقون امامي معظم وحدتنا
اختفت ودمرت كان جحيما وقادتنا تخلوا عنا
قبل بدء القذف بقليل
وجه الجنود رساله يشكون فيها حالهم
اسبوعان من التدريب لا يكفيان للزجي بنا
في الحرب وفي مدينه فارونيج الاستراتيجيه
القريبه من الحدود والتي ينتمي اليها
اغلبهاؤلاء تنام الغضب حتى بين مؤيد الحرب
مجموعات تتركو دون اتصال دون الاسلحه
اللازمه دون ادويه او دعم من المدفعيه
اتوا بيت قادمه بالفعل
الغضب العاري مستدعى ردا من وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه التي كذبت روايه جنودها وقالت ان
حجم الخسائر في صفوفهم لم يتجاوز واحدا في
المئه
ترجع صحيفه لموند الخسائر الروسيه الى
الضغط السياسي الثقيل على القياده
العسكريه لاحتلال المنطقه الاداريه
باكملها في دونيتسك التي ضمتها روسيا على
الورق في الثلاثين من سبتمبر بينما تسيطر
فعليا على نصفها فقط اضافه الى تكتيكات
باليه موروثه من ايام الجيش الاحمر ما
تزال تسيطر على القياده العليا الروسيه
والاهم زوج الجنود بالجبهات دون تدريب الى
جانب ضعف التنسيق بسبب تراجع مراكز
القياده لنحو 70 كلم عن خط الجبهه خوفا من
صواريخه مارس الامريكيه
تقول وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان معدل
الخسائر اليوميه للروس تضاعف الان ثلاث
مرات من 200 الى 600 جندي وهذا يعني انما
مجموعه
75,440 جنديا روسيا قتلوا منذ بدء الحرب
طبعا لا يمكن التحقق من دقه الارقام في ظل
حاله التعتيم الرسمي الروسي
لتبقى الحرب سجالا مفتوحا الى حين لكن
الاكيد انه مهما محتوى القياده الروسيه
ارقام جنودها القتلى فلن تستطيع احتواء
غضب الاهالي ماهر النبواني العربيه